[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm cubie HD here
and welcome to I phone 10 launched
weekend
I'm sure your subscription box is doing
just fine so I've been using iPhone 10
for about a week now and I'm getting
close to putting together my full
comprehensive video review but in the
meantime at this point
iPhone 8 and iPhone 10 are on sale next
to each other in stores starting right
now so I figure makes sense to make a
quick video highlighting the differences
between these two what makes I phone 10
iPhone 10 and what makes iPhone 8 iPhone
8 of course there are plenty of other
unique phones out there especially this
year has been I think a really great
year for phones but let's say that
there's still a lot of people who are
just picking between these two iPhone 8
or 10 so if you're one of those people
then this video is for you
so first of all the most obvious
difference is the design and I'm pretty
pumped to finally have a different
looking design for this iPhone 10 and
even if most of the rest of the phones
are nearly identical I think having a
new design is what really makes people
feel like they have a new iPhone this
year the bigger screen and the smaller
footprint finally it feels very 2017 we
all know Apple also likes to do like a
little something every year just so you
can look at your phone and know like
yeah this is the newest iPhone so this
year obviously the camera module tilted
90 degrees you can tell from pretty far
away that that's the new iPhone then of
course the nearly unmistakable top notch
display get it top notch it's okay but
it's true that's the characteristics
that make it seem really new iPhone 8 on
the other hand is familiar nearly the
exact same design as last year and a
year before and before that with the
bigger bezels the fingerprint sensor and
the home button on the front some people
will like that and gravitate towards
that because they're used to it but yeah
like I said a lot of people have been
waiting for something new and that's
what iPhone 10 is true story as I was
shooting some of this I was outside and
I guess someone was kind of stuck in
traffic in there uber and they they were
like half a block away and yelled from
the backseat of their car hey is that
the iPhone 10 and I was like yeah they
could I was impressed at that and they
said ten not X but they could tell from
their car way over there that it was the
tenth take you for what it's worth
oh yeah there's also some new colors so
iPhone 8 comes in
silver which we're pretty used to space
grey the darker one and the band-aid
gold and iPhone 10 comes in this silver
which is a different type of silver it's
really more of a white or a pearl type
of color with the very shiny aluminum
bands all the way around just an
all-around very reflective phone and the
Space Gray iPhone 10 which is definitely
a more subdued version it's darker and
the metal band around the sides isn't
quite as bright it does at least match
the Space Gray of the iPhone 8 and 8
plus so it's the same color but there's
no getting around it these are both
super reflective phones overall the
iPhone 10 design feels and looks more
modern I would say while the iPhone 8
especially when you look at other phones
that have come out in this past year -
looks kind of more stuck in the past but
the specs of the two iPhones are nearly
exactly the same not stuck in the past
at all so no need to worry about missing
out on anything in the speed or power
department but something that is
different about the hardware is the
cameras the iPhone 8 has a single camera
like you talked about in the review and
the eight plus has the dual cameras
adding a telephoto lens for portrait
mode and two times zoom iPhone 10 has
actually exactly the same sensors as
iPhone 8 plus but with slightly better
glass so a slightly wider aperture to
let in more light and now both lenses
are optically stabilized instead of just
one so you can expect slightly
occasionally better performance with
things like zoomed in video and zoomed
in photos and low-light performance for
portrait mode shots it's not a huge
difference maker so far from my
experience I mean all these phones have
great cameras but where you'll find the
bigger difference is around the front
with the selfie cameras the iPhone 10
has all these extra sensors and tech on
the front of the phone for face ID and
that also comes with a better
front-facing camera experience a selfie
on the iPhone 8 is probably very
familiar to you same as iPhone 7 and 6s
and 6 the classic warm colors decent
sharpness not the wise thing well in the
world but you know it's a pretty
standard looking selfie the iPhone 10's
front facing camera adds this portrait
selfie mode thanks to the DEF sensing
capabilities it's not very good there
tends to be some sharpness and halos
around the edges and a lot of times in
bright light it just refuses to blur
that background at all but this is
something that can continue to get
better with
software updates and I can't say I get
this phone just for that but it is an
advantage a big Hardware difference
that's gonna matter between the iPhone 8
and iPhone 10 is the lack of a
fingerprint reader on the 10 which means
you're unlocking the phone with face ID
instead of touch ID now face ID is cool
don't get me wrong for me it's worked in
a huge percentage of the time in various
conditions it's been pretty quick
unlocking basically as soon as I look at
the phone but the thing is touch ID is
still a bit better I know they say face
ID can randomly be tricked one in a
million times versus one in 50,000 for
touch ID but we had years of touch ID
getting better and better and I never
had anyone spoof my touch ID and what
really matters is touch ID is lightning
fast and almost never fails I think with
all the talk about face ID since it's
new and you know everyone trying to
spoof it all kinds of different ways we
kind of forgot about how good touch ID
was it's been the gold standard in
fingerprint readers for so long that we
kind of took it for granted
and even if face ID does get way better
with software updates like I expected to
will it ever get quite as fast as the
fingerprint reader not really sure about
that it might be a couple years but look
what it's really gonna come down to is
the displace that choice of putting a
display in between two huge bezels and a
home button and a fingerprint reader
versus stretching the screen all the way
across the entire front of the device
that choice makes all the difference in
the world there are a bunch of gestures
to learn when using the iPhone 10 some
of them easy to remember some of them a
little bit more interesting but at the
end of the day I found that you get use
of them pretty quick like a day or two
in I was fully used to it and it by that
time it does feel more modern and clean
just swiping around this pane of glass
instead of using an actual button so is
iPhone 10 worth it over iPhone 8
well obviously the full review is still
coming soon so that'll be the full
wrap-up of everything but I think the
question is it worth it comes down to
the difference in price the iPhone 10
starts at $1000 the iPhone 8 starts at
100 50 bucks less and you kind of pay
that off over time if you go on the
monthly plan I think there's no question
I phone 10 is a better design than
iPhone 8 the real question is is it a
better phone
and that will be decided pretty quickly
by you from using it so either way
thanks for watching hopefully you stay
tuned for the full review and all the
videos upcoming but that's been it talk
to you guys the next one peace
[Music]